As many of you may know, I've mentioned I've
been listening to the Howard Stern Show for
more than 20 years and he has had recently
increasingly interesting comments about Donald
Trump, including this week.
And the backstory is that Donald Trump and
Howard Stern sort of used to be acquaintances.
I don't know that I'd say friends, but Donald
Trump would regularly appear on Howard Stern's
show for years.
He would say many outrageous things.
He would rate women on scales from 1 to 10
to all sorts of different stuff.
They don't talk anymore.
Howard Stern vociferously supported Hillary
Clinton in 2016.
And from what I gather, Trump and Howard Stern
have not spoken since that time.
And Howard Stern had an interesting take about
the relationship between Trump and his own
supporters when he did a show earlier this
week on Sirius XM Radio.
And the gist of it is that Trump supporters
are mostly people that Trump despises.
Kept bearing in mind that Donald Trump grew
up rich in New York and his supporters overwhelmingly
are the types of folks that Trump would never
want at Mar a Lago or at his own hotels or
around him or whatever the case may be, that
that is the constituency that has disproportionately
made up Trump space rural, white, Midwestern
and Southern Americans, for example.
I think you get the gist of it not doesn't
apply to everybody, but let's check out the
comments and then discuss the oddity in all
of this.
Is the people Trump despises most love him
the most?
Think about it.
The the the the people who are voting for
Trump for the most part.
He wants oh my God, he wouldn't implement
a hotel disgusted with them.
He doesn't want to go look at Mar a Lago,
see if there's any people that look like you.
I'm talking to you in the audience, but dead.
The Trump voter who, you know, idolise of
the guy.
He despises you, despises you.
You're someone to grab by the pussy if you're
hot.
I know Donald, I know very well.
And I don't hate Donald.
I hate you for voting for him.
I don't hate Donald, but I'm doing his thing.
I hate you.
For voting for him, for not having an intelligence
and I name it, to see what's going on with
the Corona virus.
Not able to see what the Justice Department
is doing.
I hate you.
I don't want you here.
I want to build a wall and throw you out.
I do aim for a war.
Not for the Mexican you.
That's how I feel now.
Don't call me and start arguing with me.
Howard, you're a jerk.
You're a libtard or whatever it is you call.
I know libtard.
Trust me, I'm hardly a liberal.
Hardly.
You have no idea how no non-liberal I am.
This is pretty spot on in some ways in the
sense that they just don't get it.
It is true that the Trump voter typically
just doesn't get it.
But this is not unique to Donald Trump and
I think it bears a little more exploration.
And to understand this, you have to think
about personal versus in group priorities,
personal versus in-group frameworks.
The 2010 Tea Party is an example that I've
talked about before.
Social psychologist Jonathan Haidt talked
about this.
We interviewed him on the program a year or
so ago, maybe a little longer.
And he's written about this extensively.
He wrote about it in the book The Righteous
Mind, which if you don't have to agree with
everything that Jonathan Haidt writes but
and I don't agree with it 100 percent, but
he writes about this extensively.
And the gist is when you look at individual
versus group framing, there is a very long
history of people acting in ways that don't
seem to be optimized at their individual level,
but are optimized for their group.
And as a result, they perceive that it will
confer benefits to them.
And the best way to think about it is with
an example.
You look at the 2010 Tea Party.
All right.
2010 Tea Party ran on lower taxes for the
rich.
Don't tread on me.
Right?
So lower government regulations, lower government
involvement, don't regulate business nearly
as much.
Essentially allow more pollution, lower fuel
efficiency standards, more oil drilling, fewer
welfare benefits and social programs.
You look at who was overwhelmingly supporting
the Tea Party.
You look at the districts where the Tea Party
candidate won sometimes against an incumbent,
sort of more traditional Republican.
It was overwhelmingly people who were never
going to be rich and benefit from those tax
cuts for the rich whose taxes weren't going
to go down if Tea Partiers got their way,
who live in places that would be ravaged by
the very industrial pollution that the Tea
Party would have allowed by eliminating government
regulations and taking this laissez faire
more libertarian approach.
So you might be able to just simply say, we're
on the left.
We we we understand what these dumb people
don't.
These are just stupid people tricked into
voting against their own best interests.
And that is so the wrong approach.
They may have been tricked, but it's not that
they don't understand the policies of the
Tea Party.
They understand in many cases what the policies
are.
They've identified that those are the policies
that their group favors, even if they don't
immediately see or believe that at any point
they will personally benefit.
They believe that there will be a sort of
trickle down benefit because this is what
their group wants.
And that is why they are voting for these
policies by voting for the Tea Party.
They may not even know why.
They may not realize that their group has
actually been taken over by elites who want
to use them as a tool to achieve what's good
for them rather than for the actual voters
who are just gonna get peanuts or crumbs.
But they understand the policies and in many
cases they've identified the policies as this
is what our team or our group wants.
And I'm going to vote with the orthodoxy of
the group I'm a part of.
Apply that to the Trump voter and you see
that there is a similarity in many cases we've
categorized Trump voters before.
Some of them don't actually understand what
Trump right ran on.
They don't they have no clue what the policies
are or they don't understand them.
Could be because of cognitive limitations.
It could be people who lack education and
critical thinking skills.
Simply people who don't watch the news and
just sort of like herd vote for Donald Trump.
There's people who voted for Trump because
they have a limited understanding of the facts.
But a lot of Trump ists do understand the
policies of Trump.
And even if they don't see how it helps them
specifically, they're part of the group.
Except that the people really in Trump's group,
which is what Howard Stern points out, are
people who hang out at Mar a Lago and a lot
of these Trump supporters.
I would say the overwhelming majority are
people that pre part politics Trump would
never be associated with would be seen as
would be seeing as people that are fundamentally
beneath him.
Most Trump voters are people Trump wouldn't
be caught dead with except as part of a photo
op or rally now that he's a politician.
Now, where I disagree with Howard Stern is
this entire you know, I hate his supporters
for voting for him.
And there they're dumb.
That's an understandable, visceral reaction,
particularly when you see the way that Donald
Trump's presidency has ravaged so many aspects
of society and culture and the economy and
the U.S. standing around the world and on
and on and on.
But as a practical matter, it falls under
the umbrella of what I'd call vote shaming.
And it's it's plenty interesting to do for
a broadcast show.
And it's it's compelling and salacious, but
I don't think it's a good way to get people
to reconsider their votes.
Now, at the same time, I don't think.
That Trump is going to be defeated by convincing
his supporters not to vote for him, I've said
before.
I don't believe that that's the strategy.
I think the strategy is mobilize your key
constituencies and get people out to vote
who already agree with you.
But that being said, I don't see any particular
advantage to the approach of if you voted
for Trump, you're dumb and I hate you for
it.
Certainly we should acknowledge that.
We believe it was a mistake.
It was the wrong decision.
But I don't know that there's much to gain
from this general umbrella term of what I
would call vote shaming.
As much as it might be the obvious visceral,
emotional reaction on our side, we're going
to keep talking about this and the other stories
from today's show on The David Pakman Show
Instagram at David Pakman Show.
Also yesterday on my Instagram, I showed everybody
my cucs.
I have a whole bunch of cucumber plants which
I thought were dead.
I thought, these seeds are dead.
These aren't going to Germany.
I've got no sprouts, but I have sprouts now.
And I showed my sprouts to everybody yesterday.
You can check it out on my Instagram at David
Pakman.
Nothing better than a Corona virus victory
garden as I'm calling.
Even if the victory is gonna take a while
to get here.
Check it out.
We'll take a quick break and be back after
this.